anthony blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine est attendu demain vendredi à
bruxelles ira ensuite en pologne dans
les pays baltes et en moldavie pour
réaffirmer le soutien des etats-unis
face à la russie dans ce conflit à
washington on va tout de suite retrouvé
matthieu mabin notre correspondant
matthieu bonsoir à la veille de son
départ le pentagone a fait un point sur
la situation sur le terrain en ukraine
oui effectivement un long point est
d'ailleurs pardonnez moi je vais être un
petit peu long mais le temps médiatique
n'est pas le temps tactique et donc
après plus d'une semaine d'engagement
militaire de haute intensité dans la
moitié est et au nord ouest de l'ukraine
les officiers d'état major du pentagone
commence à avoir une lecture assez
précise de la situation technique sur le
champ de bataille ukrainien avant toute
forme d' analyses basées sur les moyens
de renseignements importants que possède
l'amérique dans cette région on a
entendu gauthier rybinski tout à l'heure
évoqué les intoxications de part et
d'autre le travail du pentagone consiste
avant tout à écarter justement et trier
les sommes colossales d'intoxication
produite par le ministère de l'intérieur
et de la défense russe d'une part mais
également il faut bien le reconnaître
par leurs homologues ukrainiens qui
savent que cette guerre est aussi une
guerre de l'information et qui participe
à épaissir ce qu'il convient d'appeler
le brouillard de la guerre selon la
formule consacrée en inondant les
réseaux sociaux de fausses informations
ainsi on peut déjà établir qu'aucun des
chiffres donnés par les états-majors
ukrainiens ou russes ne doit être
considérée comme crédible à ce stade de
la manoeuvre et si notre mission est
d'informer il faut tout simplement se
passer de bilan pour le moment il y a
des morts civiles et militaires c'est
certain dans des proportions importantes
c'est certain et de part et d'autre les
officiers du pentagone confirme que la
première phase d'invasion de l'ukraine
menée depuis l'est par des bataillons
d'infanterie mécanisée des chars avec
des canons des bataillons russe n'a pas
produit les effets espérés par moscou
effectivement deux facteurs ralentissent
aujourd'hui la progression russe d'abord
une défaillance de la chaîne logistique
ce qui confirme nos premières
informations une chaîne logistique qui a
littéralement il mobiliser les convois
blindés privée de carburants
essentiellement cette immobilisation
d'ailleurs a rendu incapable l'armée
russe d'opérer une jonction avec les
troupes héliportées cette fois et
aéroporté des parachutistes qui se
trouve en isoler constitue aujourd'hui
l'essentiel des pertes aux russes en
clair les soldats russes à pied et
coupés de leur arrière sont
littéralement tombé aux mains de l'armée
ukrainienne et même de la population en
armes ces épisodes ont été observés
notamment aux abords de kharkiv à l'est
et choristes n au nord ouest le second
facteur qui explique directement le
ralentissement de la manoeuvre russe
global c'est effectivement une
résistance massive des unités régulières
de l'armée car ukrainienne mais
également de la population constituer en
groupes d'autodéfense
cela trahit un défaut au moins du
renseignement russe qui a clairement mal
évalué l'attachement de la population
ukrainienne de l'est de l'ukraine
notamment à la nation ukrainienne et à
son président devenu la figure de la
guerre pour ce qui est des prochains
développements et après que le pentagone
a confirmé l'utilisation inattendu et
massive de l'artillerie sur des zones
d'habitation confirmé encore une fois
par le pentagone on s'attend ici à une
reprise de la manoeuvre russe à kiev
mais également à odessa cette ville de
la mer noire et enfin pour terminer le
pentagone ne confirme pas mais n'infirme
pas non plus la perte par l'ukraine de
sa suprématie aérienne ce qui est un
point essentiel du conflit nous serons
en mesure dans les prochaines heures de
vous confirmer que la colonne de chars
russes devant kiev a bel et bien été
frappé au cours des dernières heures par
des avions et craignant si c'était le
cas cela signifierait probablement que
ces avions ne décollent plus d'ukraine
ce qui constituerait un développement
majeur dans l'escaladé du conflit